most boys dream of becoming the
kingsguard rich boys from good families
get a chance smart boys stay at home and
sing songs about them instead opening
purses and thighs because the kingsguard
isn't really good for much else there
was one Kingsguard
I forgot the bastards name who swore an
oath to his dying to galleon king to
crown his daughter after him the very
night that King died this Kingsguard
crowned the king's son instead when an
old man on the small council dared to
protest this honorable Knight opened his
throat bastard died in a very civil war
he started along with the old king's son
daughter and most of their dragons and
the Kingsguard all that duty and honor
and not enough brains to figure out
which Targaryen to give it to twin
brother's even ended up on opposite
sides died with tears on their cheeks as
they cut each other down I suppose I
should think that's tragic but stupid
men do stupid things every day and
nobody cries over them Prince Aemon the
dragonknight maybe the most famous
Kingsguard who ever lived how did he die
defending Aegon the unworthy from the
Brothers of a man whom Aegon fed to his
dogs
the man's crime sleeping with one of the
many mistresses Aegon wasn't using and
the man was one of Aegon's own
Kingsguard Arthur Dayne Gerold Hightower
sure if after stories about them are
true they could swing a sword better
than most makes their lives even more of
a waste bodyguards to the maddest King
the Seven Kingdoms ever saw watching
their King burned men alive standing
guard as their king raped his queen
hiding the stark girl that Prince
Rhaegar stole away causing a war that
toppled their king and all this without
any gold or women to show for it stupid
buggers the only one with any sense was
Jaime Lannister when his father stormed
the city he put a sword through the mad
Kings back rather than die gloriously at
his post
he's still here they're not even if the
Kingsguard are the greatest Knights in
the realm Knights are just asses in
armor ride in whatever horse their
daddy's gave them
putting on a white cloak doesn't make a
man smarter or bolder it's just a pretty
little curtain
behind it is the same pile of [ __ ]